autorités politiques
bonjour coût des travaux
en détention pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par christine
bertrand du groupe la dépêche bonjour il
est là un homme en jean françois cot
bonjour et j'envoie ce coupé les
républicains ont donc tenu leurs
conseils stratégiques hier sur la ligne
politique après cette défaite historique
à la présidentielle quel était votre
position hier lors de ce complot c'est
toujours celle que je défends depuis le
début c'est moi je joue je pense que
nous sommes pineau lendemain d'une d'une
nouvelle défaite et en même temps nos
idées elles sont quand même très
présente dans l'esprit des français
cette idée selon laquelle rien ne peut
se faire dans un grand pays comme le
nôtre si on n'est pas capable à la fois
d'avoir d'assumer une politique d'
autorité de sécurité ou la présence du
régalien est attendu des français dans
le domaine sécurité de la justice de la
laïcité de l'immigration
et puis de bien sûr et puis de l'autre
du progrès au sens noble du terme un
progrès économique social scientifique
écologique c'est ça qui est l'adn de la
droite de gouvernement la droite
républicaine donc assez éloigné en fait
du discours d'extrême droite
et donc par rapport à tout cela on est
absent aujourd'hui du fait de notre
échec aux présidentielles alors que
notre vocation c'est de servir les
français et donc je réfléchis comme
d'autres à savoir comment est-ce qu'on
peut être utile aux français pendant ce
quinquennat et donc je ne suis pas dans
cette approche qui consiste à à dire
tout est nul dans ce qui est fait par
monsieur macron même si on a des
divergences majeures mais on a aussi
quand même des dépositions qu'il faut
aborder ensemble et et surtout il y a
dans la politique d' emmanuel macron un
énorme chaînon manquant justement sur le
régalien qui était un des grands échecs
quand même dû du quinquennat alors c'est
vrai que dans ce domaine là moi je suis
plutôt tendance à dire si on peut être
utile aux français il faut le dire alors
bien sûr qu'il faut qu'on ait le plus de
députés possible et donc évidemment que
c'est un débat qui ne peut être ouvert
qu'aux des législatives mais plus on
aura de députés et l'eire qui seront
élues plus on sort en situation de peser
là dessus parce que moi ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup c'est quand je vois
que monsieur macron parlait énormément
d'écologie ce qui est très bien d'europe
ce qui est très bien mais pas du tout de
ces questions régaliennes qui encore une
fois sont absolument essentielles et
pourquoi ça m'inquiète c'est tout
simplement parce que je vois derrière
tout ça une tentation d'aller chercher
des électeurs de gauche voire d'extrême
gauche et ce serait un immense
malentendu parce que les gens d'extrême
gauche qui ont voté pour lui c'est parce
qu'ils voulaient faire barrage à le pen
attention ça fait pas ça n'en fait pas
ni des macros nist ni des gens soucieux
de veiller à l'équilibré les électeurs
de droite qui ont voté pour lui c'était
plus par adhésion à ses idées mais sur
le fond vous voulez dire au deuxième
tour mais au deuxième tour même en
premier le premier bien sûr mais bien
sûr mais mais sans doute aussi qu'il
sait de casale manquantes dans le
discours d' emmanuel macron alors ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que sur le
régalien voudriez qu emmanuel macron
s'appuie sur les buveurs républicains
pour mener sa politique pendant cinq ans
je pense que en tout cas cette question
n'est pas médiocre et qui va bien
falloir que nous la posons au lendemain
des législatives
parce que si je pense qu'en plus c'est
dans l'intérêt des français et c'est
dans l'intérêt de tous les protagonistes
je pense que monsieur macron doit
entendre que son élection et quand même
fondé pour une bonne part au 2e tour sur
le rejet de l'extrême droite et c'est
tant mieux moi j'ai assumé d'avoir voté
pour emmanuel macron sans aucun état
d'âme moi je fais pas partie des gens
qui mettent maquereau et le pen sur le
même plan c'est même une évidence pour
un parti de gouvernement et pour
l'histoire de la droite et puis pour
l'histoire la france parce que c'est pas
une page blanche l'histoire de france on
sait ce que c'est que l'extrême droite
et l'extrême gauche et puis deuxièmement
parce que je pense que c'est aussi
l'intérêt de monsieur macron d'avoir
dans ce quinquennat une base plus élargi
justement compte tenu du contexte
général mais c'est vrai que c'est un
débat qu'on ne peut avoir qu au
lendemain du deuxième tour des
législatives de quelle manière qu'on
comprenne gare de de quelle manière vous
souhaitez qu'il tienne compte de vous de
votre sensibilité sur ces questions de
régalien en fin de quinquennat il avait
déjà remise intérieure gérald darmanin
qui était issu de vos rangs pour vous
qu'est-ce qu'il faut d'autres baissé de
viège moi je fais une grande différence
entre ce qui relève du débauchage
individuel de ce qui relève d'un choix
politique voilà les débauchages
individuels c'est sympathique mais c'est
des choix de carrière ce qui moi me
paraît important c'est les plaques
tectoniques en fait c'est qu'est-ce qui
organise un paysage politique alors en
même temps je sais qu'un certain nombre
de gens dire oui mais si on fait ça ça
veut dire que l'alternance du prochain
coup ce sera forcément les extrêmes ce
que je ne crois pas du tout d'abord
parce que cinq ans c'est très long et
que l'on peut parfaitement imaginer
pendant deux trois ans
apporter un certain nombre de réformes
et c'est ce qui compte c'est les débuts
du quinquennat c'est pas les femmes
quinquennat les fans quinquennat parfois
cédé fin de règne depuis la salle sera
particulièrement dans le cas de monsieur
mâcon ce qu'on pourra pas se représenter
une troisième fois mais ce qui va
compter c'est l'impulsion donnée de
trois premières années toutes ces
réformes qui n'ont pas été fait
malheureusement je pense évidemment aux
retraites je pense à la question des
finances publiques je pense à la
question de la sécurité de la laïcité
j'ai les républicains pourraient
apporter des idées de textes par exemple
qui pourrait être votée par la majorité
comment vous voulez travailler toute la
semaine la majorité et tout est possible
malheureusement prononcée contre un
terrible contre exemple c'est tout ce
qui s'est passé depuis cinq ans ou en
réalité quasiment rien n'a été
acceptée par la majorité macro nist de
ce que proposait la droite sauf dans le
cadre d'un rapport de force que pouvait
établir la majorité sénatoriale qui est
à droite et qui était parfaitement
conduite pour justement rééquilibrer les
choses mais dès lors qu'il s'agissait de
le proposer sans rapports de force vous
étiez sûr que c'était non pas seule
raison que cette savenay
de l air donc moi j'ai c'est tout ça qui
est pas possible via vous pouvez pas
avoir d'un côté un discours officiel de
monsieur macro on est dans la
bienveillance on n'a pas deux camps ont
fait siffler personnes et puis de
l'autre la réalité qui est évidemment
dès que la droite républicaine propose
un truc comme ça vient de la droite on
en veut surtout pas c'est ça qui va pas
et je pense qu'on ne peut pas continuer
comme si l'on était parce que ce serait
un grand malentendu dans
l'interprétation des résultats de ce
deuxième tour est ce que ça veut dire
qu'en amour vous pourriez vous mettre
d'accord sur certains textes que vous
feriez ensemble quels fonds est ce que
ça pourrait prendre cette tout est
peut-être que tout est possible et ça va
même au delà des textes que l'on vote au
parlement je je aujourd'hui vous savez
moi j'ai une vision
fonctionnement de nos institutions
qui est très liée au pragmatisme et à
l'efficacité
je vois le rôle majeur que joue
aujourd'hui les maires les déblais
mairie les départements les régions
quelque chose que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'évoquer mais
jamais on n'aurait pu vacciner les
français comme ça a été fait dans la
crise sanitaire si les mères n'avaient
pas organiser les centres de vaccination
les grandes politiques de sécurité elles
sont menées par les tables elles sont
menées aussi par les maires je peux en
porter témoignage amant les police
municipale armée des caméras de
vidéosurveillance les partenariats que
les maires à nîmes avec parquet avec la
police nationale la police municipale
avec les principaux de collèges lab le
plus souvent ce sont des élus locaux
dans les domaines de l'aide sociale et
départements mais mon associé et
bien sûr c'est ça qui doit changer en
rien pas le fric edouard philippe est en
train de mener au niveau de raison
sûrement j'en sais rien mais mais en
tout cas ce que je vois c'est que
l'impulsion de l'exécutif dans ce
domaine et pas n'est pas là et par
exemple le fait qu'on ait interdit aux
maires d'être parlementaire est une
énorme bêtise parce qu'aujourd'hui
parce qu'aujourd'hui et députés sont
complètement hors sol en vérité
complètement hors sol je parle même pas
des sénateurs qui sont censés
représenter les territoires et les élus
locaux et qui n'ont plus le droit d'être
élus locaux c'est
di cule est en réalité ça crée un
éloignement encore plus important de
paris par rapport au territoire jusqu'à
ce que dit qu'on marche juste pour pour
savoir sur ces sujets là vous avez de la
tuer non
ya pas mal les pas comme vous dites y'a
pas des auditions pas de raison plus en
plus j'ai vu que la ligne de l air c on
ne parle pas on ne parle pas donc on
s'incline
dise pas que c'est pas une bonne chose
je pense que ce qui est important en
tout cas c'est que ce soit fait au
lendemain des législatives
voilà
comment ça sera pas trop tapisserie il
ya quelques jours dans le journal du
dimanche vous parliez d'un accord du
programme un accord de programme on
essaye manuel macron l'ailer voir lui
dsk faire ça au lendemain des
législatives c'est pas trop tard en tout
cas c'est mieux que rien mais il nous
restera cinq ans à faire quand même donc
les cinq années il faut les faire et je
pense que en réalité c'est compatible
d'avoir une ligne ou hier vous avez rien
fermer votre indépendance et en même
temps d'avoir un accord de programmes
comme en majorité présidentielle est
vide et si l'idée c'est pas mon idée
originelle mais moi après tout
l'important c'est qu'on essaie de
trouver un accord c'est de faire en
sorte qu'elle plus de députés et leurs
possibles en fait parce que les députés
aient l'air ces deux qui vont porter
cette politique on sait pertinemment que
les députés d'extrême droite et les
députés d'extrême gauche vont mener une
opposition extrêmement violente et il
faut bien le dire démagogique comme
d'habitude cirque qu'est ce qui est
l'adn un parti extrémiste que ce soit le
front national ou ce soit elle est fille
de mélenchon mon idée c'est de jouer sur
les peurs des gens c'est de cet excité
au maximum de susciter des tensions
et de s'assurer que rien ne marche ce
quand un problème est réglé c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour l'extrême droite
ou l'extrême gauche forcément moi
j'avais j'avais vu ça il ya quelques
années quand j'avais porté la loi
d'interdiction de la burqa par exemple
d'un sur l'espace public qui était pour
moi un message extrêmement fort de
réaffirmation de la laïcité de de
l'identité des femmes dans notre
république également sur des questions
de sécurité évidentes dans le premier
qui avait dit qu'il fallait pas de lois
c'est tariq ramadan va bien sûr le
deuxième c'était jean marie le pen dit
nono mais un décret ça suffit bas
évidemment parce que pour l'un comme
pour l'autre quand un problème est réglé
c'est une mauvaise nuit elle voit là et
c'est ça qui en réalité est au coeur de
débats aujourd'hui je veux dire que vous
souhaitez vous mettre autour de la table
avec le gouvernement le premier ministre
qui sera nommé écrire un programme
commun l air lr m si ce n'est un
programme commun ou tout en tout cas un
pacte qui nous permettraient ensemble
d'imaginer comment
apporter des réponses sur des sujets qui
aujourd'hui sont pas traitées le
pourquoi la question de la sécurité est
typique il ya un chaînon manquant énorme
les villes où il n'y a pas de police
municipale armée où il n'y a pas de
coordination de la police nationale ça
marche pas ce que politicien elle peut
pas tout faire et les taux de
délinquance sont élevés
la question par exemple de
l'organisation sanitaire est une
question qui nous a sauté au visage avec
la crise du coc vide tout ça s'est fait
de manière très empirique
on voit bien qu'il faut mieux articuler
les choses
la question de la laïcité n'est pas
traitée correctement il ya encore des
chaînons manquants des domaines dans
lesquels les gens sont démunis face à
des rapports de force au quotidien qui
passent jamais au journal de 20h mais
qui sont des problèmes pour nous et on
imagine que ça j'en avais parlé en
comité stratégique commencé accueillis
dans votre parti comment qu'elle songe à
écouter
en réalité vous avez deux thèses qui
s'oppose quand même vous l'avez compris
vous avez ceux qui considèrent qu'il
faut absolument
ne rien discuté avec en marche d'abord
parce qu'on n'a pas confiance parce que
c'est et puis ensuite parce qu on fait
le calcul que ben en 2027 il faut qu'on
soit une alternance total et qu'on le
soit tout de suite c'était la majorité
est très calme bien sûr c'est la
majorité pour diverses raisons voilà qui
sont qui n'ont pas toujours très la
grande politique importe quoi la plus
petite politiquement et puis d'autres
qui sont peut-être un peu qu'ils ont
pris un peu de recul c'est mon cas
vous le savez et qui pour autant
continue participer au débat public et
qui pensent que ce qui compte c'est que
les choses soient faites pour les
français munich aidé hier on parle d
soutenu je préfère non joue pas voté
mais j'ai papoté pas pris part au vote
mais pas tout le monde connaît ma
position puis enfin voter on n'est pas
en train de voter des lois non plus et
des positions politiques
oui parce que quand une fois moi je suis
pas là pour ses pages pas l'âme d'un
dissident c'est pas c'est pas tout à
fait ma feuille d'or mais pour autant je
pense que c'est des débats qui doivent
vivre qui sont des débats majeurs et
puis d'ailleurs ça a évolué puisque au
début j'étais très très seul puis j'ai
vu qu'un certain nombre d'autres avaient
fini quand même
n'a pas pris part au vote parce qu'on a
entendu parler de
moi je suis pas expert comptable vous
est ce qu'un à d'autres non mais peu
importe je crois que c'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut poser les choses réalité vous
avez beaucoup de gens y compris sont pas
dans ce comité stratégique ce que ça un
petit cénacle comité stratégique ce même
pas un truc statutaires et qui partagent
cet avis et beaucoup d'élus
par exemple sur la même ligne que
nicolas sarkozy sur ce sujet là alors ça
ça mérite d'être noté c'est pas si
fréquent mais cela étant avec deux
divergences quand même de différence
quand même la première c'est que moi
j'ai soutenu ardemment valérie pécresse
et je pense qu'on n'a pas tout à fait la
même voie quand on l'a s'est beaucoup
engagé sept succès à sa famille
politique et quand on l'a pas fait
et deuxième essai sur l'histoire d'andré
en tout cas moi je pense que ça peut
avoir du sens que d'avoir un successeur
qui soit sa famille politique je pensais
même une fierté bon
et puis la deuxième différence c'est que
je comprends moi je parle avec lui mais
je comprends qu'il ait pour des
débauchages individuels en fait puisque
lui son idée c'est de de promettre à
emmanuel macron de lui ramener entre
guillemets des députés individuellement
bon c'est pas du tout ma démarche sanaa
pour moi aucun sens le débauchage
individuel ce qui a du sens c'est un
acte politique c'est à dire l'idée que
le party les républicains à travers le
mans terre et être casé chambres
parlementaires mais mais mais que que
cette formation politique disent aux
français nous voulons vous être utile on
n'est pas simplement dans un calcul à
trois bandes pour que la prochaine fois
vous votiez pour nous nous voulons vous
être utile nous voulons apporter sur un
certain nombre de sujets des réponses
que en marche ne peut pas apporter parce
que c'est une majorité hétéroclite
composée de gens sympas sûrement mais
qui sont très loin du terrain qu'ils
connaissent pas parce qu'ils sont pas
issus comme on l'est nous de nos
territoires vous craignez les fameux
débauchages individuels que dont paris y
est je crains pas je les vois qu'est ce
que ça va affaiblir une nouvelle fois
votre famille politique et c'est la
nature humaine
c'est parce que ce qui s'est passé hier
jean françois copé c'est pas un peu
mettre la poussière sous le tapis les
repousser le problème après les mines a
écouté ça c'est bien sûr mais c'est un
choix qui a été fait par la majorité des
gens qui étaient autour de la table qui
secoue le principe c'est qu'une majorité
et puis il ya une minorité donc partir
du moment où une majorité disent on en
parle qu'après les législatives
personne chez galilée qui avait dit mais
moi je me suis rendu compte que c'est la
terre qui tourne autour du soleil et à
l'époque deux c'est étonnant c'est le
soleil qui tourne autour de la tête et
puis un jour il s'est retrouvé devant
l'inquisition le tribunal de
l'inquisition on lui dit de nant c'est
pas vrai donc on a tellement menacées
qui dit bon ok ok je me suis trompé et
puis disent que
jusqu'à une personne qu'on n'entend pas
et pourtant c'est le deuxième personnage
de l'état le président du sénat gérard
larcher est ce qu'il ya il s'était
exprimé est ce que sur calais n'ont pas
à ma connaissance vous comprenez ceux ci
l'on a je n'ai absolument aucun ni
commentaire gérard larcher sait s'il
parle quand il pose juste devoir parler
c'est pas mon sujet est-ce que vous pour
finir juste sur les débauchages
individuels
on n'a pas parlé de damien abad et
philippe juvin qui pourrait quitter
votre famille politique ah bon parce que
si j'ai fait la connaissance qu'ils
allaient quitter ma famille politique
qui pourrait à bon non ils l'ont dit
il ya des rencontres entre les cartes
normal j'en sais rien moi vous est ce
mieux parce que c'est à faiblir aient
jamais entendu qu'ils avaient dit qu'ils
quittent leur famille politique non mais
quand il hier philippe j'ai fait un sort
du comité stratégique et dit moi je veux
que les partis de gouvernement travaille
ensemble c'est pas vraiment ce qu'il ya
écrit sur le communiqué on va vous notez
que te ment ce que je pense et c'est pas
pour ça que suscitera et c'est pas pour
ça que vous avez envie de quitter votre
famille habite ce n'est même pas en
discussion est ce que pour tourner une
page et pour faire oublier cette défaite
même si évidemment vous ne parviendrez
pas à la faire oublier il faut refonder
complètement le parti il faut changer le
nom des républicains et bâtir une toute
autre architecture pour vous je pense
que ça va au delà c'est à dire que en
réalité
l'ump et tapas et était une dynamique
absolument remarquable
sougé le nord de la présider pendant
quatre ans donc on parlait en
connaissance de cause on n'a certes pas
perdu la présidentielle en 2012 mais
enfin en 2014 nous étions plus grand
parti de france
moment j'ai quitté mes fonctions nous
venions de remporter une victoire
immense aux municipales fameuse vague
bleue donc sur laquelle nous vivons
encore aujourd'hui nous avions 70% des
villes de plus de 9000 habitants qui
était passée à droite bon après est
arrivé ce qui est arrivé on s'est
acharné sur moi dans les conditions que
vous savez épisode c'est anormal on a pu
voir la haine entre les uns et les
autres dont j'ai été le réceptacle
et puis après il ya une espèce de
descente aux enfers
lorsque nicolas sarkozy a pris les rênes
nouveau sas et appelé les républicains
et j'avais créé des sensibilités
différentes les fameux mouvement il les
a supprimés est arrivée la primaire ne
jamais faire de primaires c'est un
cauchemar on l'a revu deux fois de suite
ça c'est encore plus étriqué tragédie
avec la défaite de monsieur fillon et
puis ces cinq années qui objectivement
sont un grand ratage part je retire quoi
tout cela qu'il faut tout recommencer en
fait et ne pas penser que c'est
simplement en attendant tranquillement
que ça se passe que les choses vont
changer que les français vont tout d'un
coup nous retroussons se retrouver un
nouvel amour pour nous
aujourd'hui ça ce serait un peu un peu
expéditif on va dire qu'en tout cas nos
aînés
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas seuls fillon
monsieur juppé voilà
ont participé d'une manière ou d'une
autre à tout ça bah oui cette espèce
d'obsession conte à la génération au
dessus de la mienne de tout faire pour
qu'ils aient pas de successeur c'est une
réussite vous vous dites il faut tout
changer vous verriez maître d'oeuvre de
ce changement mais moi à titre personnel
n'ont participé sans doute oui parce que
quand on a été on a exercé les fonctions
qui ont été les miens aussi bien au
gouvernement que la tête de notre parti
famille politique de notre majorité à
l'assemblée tout ça évidemment fait que
ça m'engage mais pour autant vous savez
moi je n'ai pris un peu de recul par
rapport à des fonctions exécutives
nationale j'ai conservé mes fonctions de
maire par ailleurs avocat mais je veux
participer au débat public parce que je
pense finalement qu'il ya des voix qui
doivent s'exprimer c'est un peu une
sorte de devoir aussi de 2,2 d'éclairer
de participer aux débats de de partager
des intuitions comme je vous prie pas
question l'accession pardon de christian
jacob est ouverte quel pourrait être le
profil d'un bon successeur à christian
jacob quelles seraient les qualités
juste parce qu'on fait
on est même tout à fait là mais il ya
une chose qui est certaine c'est que si
c'est simplement pour refaire ce qui
vient d'être fait pendant ce temps on
refonde équipe loi si
je sais pas parce que là pour le coup
des gens qui n'a vraiment aucune c'est
d'ailleurs le principe parce que si on
en est ça veut dire qu'il ya aucune
incarnation aujourd'hui pour partie est
d'ailleurs je vais même vous dire mieux
je ne suis même pas certain qu'il faille
se précipiter pour le faire en réalité
je pense qu'il faut laisser un peu de
temps et que même si chacun se fait son
déjà son calcul pour 2027 jacquin sony
phobie préempter le truc parce que pour
pas laisser les autres les mêmes causes
vont produire les mêmes effets et en
regardant autour de moi hier dans à
cette réunion un certain nombre de
personnalités présentes jeu bizet bah
dis donc dire que pour certains d'entre
eux ils vont vite se détester avoir
envie de s'arrêter chez les uns et les
autres donc en réalité je vois bien
derrière tout ça il ya un système quand
même qui comme au parti socialiste se
termine à une nuance immense près c'est
plus parti socialiste est en train de se
déshonorer en allant négocier avec
l'extrême gauche quelques sièges et que
ça en dit long sur l'état de
déliquescence dans lequel sept autres
partis de gouvernement qui fut un grand
parti politique est en train de se
déshonorer
aujourd'hui écoutés et très courageuse
je peux pas vous dire autre chose moi
qui suis assez bon spécialisés des fêtes
j'ai eu la chance de connaître des
grandes victoires mais aussi quelques
quelques défaites je peux mesurer à
l'autre de mon expérience personnelle la
solidité des bd des gens et en laque en
ce qui la concerne je la trouve très
très solide en plus à les confronter une
épreuve particulière puisque elle doit
rembourser à titre personnel une somme
extrêmement importante et donc on a tous
d'une manière ou d'une autre participer
y compris l'aider à trouver des dons
parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
situation folle au regard de
l'engagement public et politique qui est
celui beaucoup d'entre nous alors vous
disiez tout à l'heure que vous vouliez
d' emmanuel macron pour ce quinquennat
qui s'ouvre un quinquennat qui nous
s'ouvre sur des hospices un peu
particulière une france très clivée cas
l'analyse vous faites du score de
dimanche est ce que vous êtes inquiet
pour la suite
enfin inquiet vous pensez que la france
va être compliqué à gouverner d'abord je
pense que les temps que nous vivons sont
des temps difficiles et je pense que
nous ne passons pas suffisamment de
temps à partager avec les français la
réalité des choses cette campagne est un
grand rendez vous manqué on sait rien
dit d'important dans cette campagne on
est partis sur des délires ces théories
stupide de zemmour qui consiste qui
caricaturait qui clivent est
connecté une tentation chez certains
[Musique]
c'est évidemment un risque qui existe
c'est pour ça qu'il faut être très ferme
et que j'ai regretté qu'on ne soit pas
suffisamment
parce que c'est pas notre histoire du
tout cette histoire là l'histoire
l'extrême droite mais en revanche une
fois je suis franchement une ligne rouge
j'avais la droite décomplexée pour moi
c'était ça c'est une droite qui était
parfaitement étanche avec l'extrême
droite et parce qu'on était étanche avec
l'extrême droite qu'on ne s'est rien
passé on pouvait tout dire et c'est
comme ça qu'on a évoqué que j'ai
évoquées moi à titre personnel des
débats majeurs parler tout à la loi sur
la burqa mais j'ai parlé des dérives
auxquelles on consiste non on assistait
dans sa roue de quartier avec des
individus qui instrumentalisent la
religion en l'occurrence la religion
musulmane a des fans de violence que
sans aller jusqu aux actes terroristes
évidemment que nous combattons de toutes
nos forces mais j'ai été avec d'autres à
organiser l'ump à l'époque un débat sur
la laïcité qui a été extrêmement
critiquée par la gauche ce dont j ai
rien à faire parce que ce sont des
sujets de réalité quand on voit ce qu'il
en est aujourd'hui donc mais vous pensez
que par exemple eric ciotti peut aller
voir du côté des méchants sont les
personnalités comme ça non mais vous
dites oui un réseau
on va certainement pas rentrer là dedans
je peux comprendre la tentation de tel
ou tel d'entre vous à vouloir mettre des
noms c'est pas mon problème mon sujet
c'est des tentations cd cd comment dire
des mouvements lourds dans la des
évolutions de lourdes dans la halle dans
le donne dans le
moi ce qui m'importe en cette affaire-là
c'est qu'on comprenne que cette élection
présidentielle était un grand rendez
vous manqué parce que les vrais sujets
n'ont jamais été abordé ni emmanuel
macron ni marine le pen n'ont voulu à
aucun moment dans le débat du deuxième
tour les aborder en fait et donc on sait
rien dit d'important et c'est ça qui moi
me gêne beaucoup c'est que pendant ce
temps là vous avez des millions de
français qui se disent mais en fait
c'est quoi la suite ou et la perspective
et à l'heure où nous parlons je ne sais
pas vous dire quelle est la feuille de
route de ce nouveau quinquennat pour
donner un exemple et pour donner un
souffle démocratique emmanuel macron
veut refonder les institutions
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec les
pistes qu'il a proposé la
proportionnelle le septennat peut-être
des élections législatives à moyen terme
écoutez si c'est pour moi c'était
vraiment la meilleure manière de revenir
à la troisième république c'est à dire à
tout ce qui a conduit à l'effondrement
de la france
c'est d'ailleurs une manie des
responsables politiques de vouloir
absolument faire du débat institutionnel
la réponse aux problèmes des français
c'est la seule chose qui marche et les
institutions c'est pas l'essentiel elles
permettent à une majorité de gouverner
et d'assumer un bilan c'est bien texte
que vous votre bon c'est pas un texte
que votre bouche la majorité issue value
parlementaire colombie deuxièmement je
pense que c'est le dernier des problèmes
nous avons des problèmes de sécurité des
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat des
problèmes de réindustrialisation de la
france de poèmes de perspectives
économiques sociales environnementales
scientifique nous n'avons pas de
problème institutionnel parce qu'on a un
exécutif solide et un parlement donc il
faudrait renforcer la mission comme
contrôleur du gouvernement les textes
existent personnes les appliques merci
beaucoup jean françois copé d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin c'est du foot à la
une de la dépêche du midi c'est qui nous
fait vivre et qui remonte en ligue 1
merci cristal bertrand merci beaucoup
jean françois copé
[Musique]